hello and welcome to this session on
packages in python
today we are going to talk about how can
we leverage packages and create in
python
so now let's discuss what's in it for us
today
we will discuss what are python packages
how do we create those packages and we
will be supporting them with an example
and then we will discuss different ways
to access python packages
so as we have discussed in our earlier
sessions that you know we can create
modules but packages are one level above
they allow you to structure your modules
in a more organized fashion and we will
see how
now what are python packages
packages are the same
as a directory they are like you're
creating a directory structure and
within the directory you can create sub
packages and modules in a structured way
making the sub packages and modules easy
to access and easy to understand
so basically it's like an analogy to a
folder
like you create structured folders in
your computer and organize your data you
create subfolders so that you can easily
navigate and remember where you have
kept what
that's the same concept which is
applicable in python packages
packages helps us keep other sub
packages and modules to be used by the
other user when necessary so basically
when the other
programmers or the python files
import the packages you have a modular
structure you have a directory structure
and it makes it easy to import
now the first step in order to create a
python package is to create init dot py
file
that underscore underscore init
underscore underscore dot py file is a
mandatory file to be kept in a package
and that's how
you signify you notify
the python interpreter that you know
there's a package which has been created
now the init.py file can be empty
if it is empty it means that all the
modules all the functions
within that particular package are
allowed to be imported
and if it is not empty then you can
specify which particular
function in a particular module is
allowed to be imported
other than that anything nothing else
will be allowed
so it's a very important file which has
to be present and we will see in our
example
now a package can be imported the same
way as we have learned in the past how a
module is imported syntactically it's
very similar and you will observe it
now here is an example of a typical
package structure and we are going to be
showing this example
now we have created a package called
music application
and the music application package has
its own init dot py file
and we have created a sample signup.p
wi-fi
in which
we will import
uh the functions from sub packages like
options playlist filter
and play
and each sub package if you see also
have their own independent dot py file
and within that you have your modules
speed repeat shuffle under options
single genre album under playlist filter
and start next previous under play
so in our example we will be invoking
certain functions in few of these files
and showing you how to invoke
functions under the modules of a sub
package
now let me show you
my package structure
now this is my jupyter
and under my jupiter notebook the root
folder i have the music application
now if you see the structure as compared
to what we were showing in the
presentation
i will just
now here you have the music application
and under that you have init dot py
okay which is empty which means uh we
are allowing to import all the functions
and modules and then we have the
signup.py
so indeed in this we are going to invoke
our sub packages options and play so we
are going to invoke sub package options
and play and the functions
uh within that so this is the module
speed option speed and within that we
have option underscore speed function so
i'll go to options
speed
and this function we're gonna invoke
right so this is one sample invocation
and then we're gonna also invoke a
function underscore and in play
so we go to play
and then within play we are saying start
and we're going to call a function play
start
okay
so this is our sample
package structure
which we are leveraging for our example
just a description
and then uh you know you can use
different syntaxes to import the package
and within the package you can import
the
module name the sub package and the
respective module name
whatever way you want but all these
syntax
says are available to you in python
in order to
uh invoke the relevant function within
those packages and modules
so if you see this
signup.py we are using this syntax
import
package name
module name which is the speed module
okay
you can also use import
package name sub package name then the
module name etc so you know all those
relevant options are available to you
now let's try to invoke uh
certain sub packages and modules so like
i am writing
uh import option speed
so i'm gonna be invoking
options
speed and then i'm going to import the
function option underscore speed
so this is
one this is that invocation and then i
have import play.start and then i'm
pointing the function play start
which is
play
start play start
okay and if you run and then similarly
within the play previous
i'm playing the play previous function
you run it and you get the you print the
sops
which are there
similarly you can import playlist
underscore filter dot singer
this is another package
and i am calling it in from my
sample
jupiter notebook file
now you can also invoke your
sign up dot py file directly here
what you just need to do is
type percentage run signup.py and just
run it and all the commands
all these syntaxes within that file will
get executed
so with this what we have learned is
that you know you can packages is a very
simple concept in python it is just
about structuring your modules
structuring your sub packages
and
keeping it in a you know understandable
and a
reusable manner so that you can easily
point to the correct module and allow
others to import it for uh utility or
for you know code inheritance so that
makes the life easy for the developers
also
so i hope you all had a great learning
session and i'll meet you in my next
session thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here